it's hard to think of any industry
that's enjoyed more success over the
past 20 years or so than big Pharma more
than 131 million people that's
two-thirds of all adults in the United
States report that they're taking at
least one prescription drug currently
that's a significant increase from the
year 2000 when around half of American
adults said they were doing so the
percentage of people taking five or more
prescription drugs has nearly doubled
since the turn of the century spending
on prescription drugs in that period has
more than tripled drugs that supposedly
treat psychological issues like
unhappiness or lack of self-control have
done especially well from 1991 to 2018
SSRI prescriptions increased by over
three thousand percent
roughly half the country either takes
the potentially mind-altering drug
ozempic to lose weight or know someone
taking it now given big pharma's
tremendous success you think that by now
they would have solved a lot of the
health problems facing Americans or at
least made progress in resolving these
problems
but the opposite is true
average life expectancy is declining
suicide rates are going up
so are the rates of obesity drug
addiction cancer among young adults
how is that possible
how is the pharmaceutical industry
succeeding financially while failing in
every other area that matters
how can they have so many people on so
many medicines and yet at the same time
everyone is only getting sicker and less
healthy
part of the answer is that many drugs
created by big Pharma aren't even
intended to alleviate health problems
anymore
they're designed instead to cause more
death and suffering
big Pharma is churning out record
amounts of sterilization drugs abortion
drugs suicide drugs especially in Canada
where the government has begun putting
down the undesirables who don't even
have a terminal illness they are
euthanizing human beings like stray dogs
and hardly anyone is objecting to it
more than half of all abortions are now
performed using drugs from
pharmaceutical companies so-called
puberty blockers which can cause
lifelong complications are not
prescribed to children under the age of
18 more than twice as often as they were
just a few years ago
the rest of big pharma's catalog the
drugs that are at least allegedly
beneficial to Patients health
have had a lot of marketing behind them
other than New Zealand we are the only
country that allows drug companies to
Market directly to Consumers
this means that the pharmaceutical
industry can sell not just the
medication but also the illness that the
medication is supposed to cure
do you have such and such symptoms then
you might have this disease here's a
drug that can help
diagnosis and prescription in one
30-second advertisement how convenient
fortunately for big Pharma Pharma the
U.S government has also granted them
immunity from lawsuits even when their
products injure people which they quite
often do
maybe the most important single reason
for big Pharma success though is media
coverage
and in particular media coverage that
the drug companies have paid for
pharmaceutical companies recently began
spending more on Advertising than they
do on research and development in 2020
the year of the great pandemic Pfizer
spent 12 billion dollars on marketing
compared to just nine billion dollars on
R D companies like ABV and Johnson
Johnson and Bayer and many other Pharma
companies posted similar numbers
now what does all this money buy you
if you turn on any cable or network News
Channel you know the answer to that
question it buys incessant
advertisements that air during every
commercial break
and other than that although the
networks of course will never admit it
it also buys positive coverage after all
if the networks criticize big Pharma
they stand to lose millions in
advertising dollars
every single news report you see on TV
is sponsored by big Pharma
now you might have noticed that the
entire national news media
um kind of staying on this point here is
currently freaking out over the shortage
of the drug Adderall Adderall is
manufactured by Teva Pharmaceuticals
although they're competitors that make
other versions of the drug all of a
sudden Adderall is really hard to find
and here's one recent report from ABC
Action News on the shortage and I want
you to to see and watch how they frame
this issue listen
a shortage of ADHD medication is leaving
some parents in limbo and they're
wondering if they're going to have
enough pills to help their children yeah
experts say shortages of medications are
not rare but the shortage of ADHD
medications is in a category of its own
our Vanessa Ariza spoke with one mother
who says it's a game of roulette when it
comes to her daughter's medicine she
also spoke to an expert who may have a
better idea of when the problem will
slow down
meet six-year-old Ayanna a beam of light
with a love for lyrics
[Music]
her mom Jessica McBride says this is her
lovable daughter on a good day when
she's on her ADHD medication they
finally found one that works well for
Ayanna last fall within about a week of
being on it she was finally able to
memorize her sight words that she'd been
working on for months you know she was
finally able her brain was able to slow
down enough for her to focus
hmm what will that six-year-old do
without her stimulates
this is a medical crisis after all the
six-year-old has trouble sitting still
to memorize sight words when she's not
drugged
which makes her very similar to almost
every other six-year-old that has ever
lived on the planet but this mother
wants her six-year-old to be less like a
six-year-old because it's very
inconvenient to have a six-year-old
acting like a six-year-old in the home
and that's why she desperately needs the
drug and by she I mean the mother not
the child
the mother needs the child to be drug so
the child is not such a burden on her
the mother
the anchor says that the shortage of
ADHD medication is leaving parents
wondering quote if they're going to have
enough pills to help their children but
of course ADHD drugs for kids are really
meant to help the parents
think about what a revealing line that
is though for a moment
well there's two lines there the first
is about the sight words by the way
uh if your six-year-old has not
memorized all of her sight words in a
few months that's normal
that is a normal six-year-old thing
I've had three six-year-olds I know what
I'm talking about we are days away from
the Durbin Accords the greatest threat
to the U.S Dollar's Global dominance in
the past 80 years on August 22nd the
brics nations are expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the U.S and
the dollar as Cornerstone to the Global
Financial system you can protect your
IRA or 401K from The Fallout from this
Landmark Announcement by diversifying
with gold from Birch gold historically
gold has been a safe haven in times of
high uncertainty which is right now when
currencies fail gold is a safe haven how
much more time does the Dollar have
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers find out why we're texting
Walsh to 989898 and get your free info
kit on gold if a central bank digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to depend on again
text Walsh
298-9898 when it comes to carrying your
valuables or self-defense items in your
vehicle most people feel that they have
to choose between safety or convenience
someone breaking into your car will
typically check the glove box under the
seats the center console and well now we
can outsmart them with the headrest safe
which gives you convenience and peace of
mind this is a head rest the header safe
is exactly what it sounds like you can
place your standard headrest in your car
with our easy access safe access safe
you just pull the side part and then you
can either use your fingerprint use a
key or manually type in the code to open
the safe uh and that's it there's a lot
of stuff in there that you need right
there very
very convenient and also tricky they'll
never know the criminals unless they're
watching this ad so let's hope they
don't I don't have a lot of criminals
watching the show that's a good thing
there's no way that anyone could know
that your headdress safe is even there
and even if they did there's no way they
could get it open without using one of
the three methods to unlock it so the
address headrest safe has a universal
design that allows it to fit all
vehicles and the best part is these come
in a variety of colors to make the
interior of your car and match it
perfectly I have their black leather
Vulcan headrest for my vehicle and I
love it I took my family out to dinner
last week and the restaurant only had
valet parking well thanks to my head
rest safe I was able to leave valuables
in my car that I wanted to keep extra
safe depending on the day I'll put
self-defense items cash or medications
in this safe it gives me peace of mind
knowing that it'll stay out of the hands
of our kids valets or Intruders so what
are you waiting for save a hundred
dollars at the headrestsafe.com with
promo code wall so check out that's the
headrestsafe.com promo code Walsh
but there's also a statement from the
news anchor
um
which assumes as a matter of fact that
the only possible way for parents to
help their children is by giving them
pills
now what's the scientific basis for that
claim later on ABC Action News provides
an expert and here's what this expert
has to say
this is a really really difficult
shortage a lot of patients require this
medication just to function on a daily
basis that's Michael Daniel he's with a
nonprofit organization American Society
of Health System pharmacists initially
he says the shortage of ADHD medication
was due to manufacturing now he says one
aspect of the drug drought is due to
demand more people being diagnosed with
ADHD resulting in more people needing
the drug in this case it's really hard
to understand how much demand is out
there so manufacturers can scale up
production but they really don't know
how much to make
so the expert who affords legitimacy to
the idea that six-year-olds need ADHD
medication his name Michael ganio he's
with the American Society of Health
System pharmacists he says that a lot of
patients quote require this medication
just to function on a daily basis
therefore he says the ADHD shortage is
very difficult
so we might have uh we might have an
epidemic of six-year-olds not memorizing
sight words think of the devastation
now what's left unstated in that report
is that the American Society of Health
System pharmacists is sponsored by big
Pharma they admitted on their website
the the most recent mid-year conference
lists Pfizer as a platinum sponsor
so these are the experts that the
pharmaceutical industry launders uh
so-called through so-called news reports
in order to convince you that ADHD is a
real disorder and that your kid has it
needs the drugs
the quality of medical professional they
throw on television to tell you that
your six-year-old needs a lifetime
supply of psychiatric medication
so that she'll be docile and compliant
as if that's how a six-year-old is
supposed to be
but these experts are really PR people
okay this is marketing they're doing
as you have to prove that point the same
expert Michael ganil popped up in a PBS
news article on Adderall it's entitled a
perfect storm led to an ADHD medication
shortage here's why
once again the expert explains that the
Adderall shortage is really frustrating
presumably because patients desperately
need the drug PBS agrees they reported
that Millions who rely on the drugs have
been left with uncertainty frustration
and bureaucratic hassles
National Geographic was even more
melodramatic they wrote as adderall
shortage continues people with ADHD
struggle to stay afloat the article
quotes an adult who says that who's been
diagnosed with ADHD and he says the
quote it doesn't take much for us to
drown
National Geographic added that quote
some adults with ADHD are now forced to
navigate life while unmedicated
oh man can you imagine American adults
are having to figure out how to navigate
life without their regular dose of
stimulants
God forbid the heart navigating life
unmedicated
how will you ever do it I mean how can
these people possibly live and deal with
normal distraction in boredom without
their chemical crutches
now of course prior to the invention of
ADHD medicine and ADHD itself everybody
lives without these drugs and not one
single person died because of it
yet now a shortage of these drugs the
ones that everyone was was fine without
since forever represent some kind of
existential crisis people are drowning
without them
Mrs South pharmaceutical company wants
you to feel they want you to feel that
with that that this drug they're giving
you is a life raft that you have to
cling to and if you if you don't have it
you will drown somehow
the by administration of course agrees
that this is a major problem they want
everybody hopped up on as many drugs as
possible accordingly CNN reports that
the FDA and D.A are now calling on drug
makers to boost manufacturing amid
ongoing shortages of prescription
stimulants
CNN blamed the shortage on the quote
surge in demand for prescription
stimulants during the kova 19 pandemic
especially among adults
of course this is not the first time
there's been a rush to manufacture and
push out drugs allegedly because of the
pandemic and we all know how well it
worked out the first time
in any case it's the pandemic's fault
they say they're blaming the shortage of
the Adderall on on the pandemic just
like they blame everything on the
pandemic but here's the thing
if the pandemic increased ADHD by such
an enormous degree
then that only shows that ADHD is not a
real disease it's a concept invented by
the medical industry in its never-ending
pursuit to medicalize and subsequently
profit off of every inconvenient human
trait and behavior you know the fact
that more people suddenly came down with
ADHD when they were locked in their
homes absolutely proves that this
disorder is simply a way of categorizing
normal boredom and restlessness which is
all extremely human and again normal
that would explain why ADHD diagnoses
somehow increased by two-thirds from
1998 to 2016. it would explain why these
diagnoses increased again during the
pandemic by roughly 20 percent for some
demographic groups including young women
you know you might uh you might notice a
pattern here that that as we have more
and more distractions in life that's one
of the it's one of the changes from the
90s into the uh you know 2010s and into
2020 is that they're more and more
distractions okay we've got you
introduced smartphones and social media
and people are on their screens
constantly 10 hours a day of screen time
okay so as as there are more
distractions in life people become more
distracted
is that because we all have a mental
disorder or are we just responding to
our environments in ways that are
actually pretty normal
it's not like uh some new objective ADHD
test was developed that explains these
numbers they're just making up criteria
that mean nothing and diagnosing every
patient who walks in the door take a
look at how the CDC defines ADHD if
you're skeptical the CDC says that
children have ADHD if they do the
following make careless mistakes or take
unnecessary risks Daydream a lot forget
or forget or lose things a lot squirm or
fidget and have a hard time resisting
temptation
my God the epidemic is worse than I
thought I mean apparently literally
every child who has ever lived on earth
is infected
apologists will try to claim that the
diagnostic criteria isn't really that
broad you know there are other ways of
determining whether a child really has
it or not
they'll even claim that ADHD can be
detected in the brain with brain scans
and yet you'll notice something that the
disorder is never diagnosed with brain
scans why is that
supposedly it's in the brain you can see
it in the brain and why not why you
diagnose it that way just take you don't
need to talk to a psychologist a
therapist anybody counselor
no conversations take a child to get a
brain scan
but they never diagnose it that way ever
that's because it really is as broad as
it seems every child can be diagnosed
with it every single one if you want
your child to have it they have it if
you want the drugs you can get them
apart from the shortage of course
you can indeed diagnose every kid on the
planet with ADHD just like you can
diagnose every unhappy masked
middle-aged woman with long covid the
diagnosis is about as rigorous
that's because ADHD like long covid is
not a real medical diagnosis it is a
category error
okay these are real human behavior ADHD
is a is describes a set of real human
Behaviors real human traits
but then to determine has determination
has been made by the medical industry by
the pharmaceutical industry that profits
off of this determination to categorize
these behaviors and traits as disordered
that is a value judgment on their part
it's not a medical judgment
and it's a value the value judgment is
oh people shouldn't act this way it's
bad to act this way or be this way
so which all amounts to this being a
made-up illness that's used to describe
normal human responses to a modern
environment which is filled with
distractions the solution
which no one ever talks about because it
wouldn't make big farm any money
is to either change your environment to
the extent that you can
or learn to deal with it
learn to cope with it
if everyone did that it's very possible
that the pharmaceutical companies would
lose money in fact a lot of money
but maybe the metrics that matter like
suicide rate life expectancy drug
overdoses and so on
maybe those would finally start moving
in the right direction if you'd like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed